most guys have this unrealistic
expectation that they want every girl to
like them be confident not arrogant and
that's the iron if you think about it
you only get good at that if you deal
with rejection right have you ever
approached a guy
and have you ever been rejected there's
also the view of like our woman is
weaker than a man and there's nothing
wrong with that I think that Society
openly discriminates against men way
more than women
how can single men overcome anxiety or
fear of rejection in the dating world
I'll answer that one yeah I literally I
think single men need to actually
partner with other men men like myself
men like yourself and actually learn
from other men and I think they need to
get to the bottom of why that's
happening with they need to do their own
mindset
it's literally because it's rejection
right he said for me rejection is all
about what you make it mean it's not the
rejection it's the meaning that you
ascribe to that rejection what do you
make that mean I'm not good enough I'm
not tall enough I'm not rich enough as
opposed to just one person so it really
is cultivating an abundance mindset
there are so many women and great people
out there and once you've got an
abundant mindset it's a bit like I don't
know it's like I don't know it's like I
don't know going to McDonald's and
they've run out of your burger do you
get upset by it you go and find another
one isn't it right or you missed the bus
you wait for another one why is it when
it comes down for human beings we feel
oh my God that's rejected it's just okay
one person rejected you now if you're
really clever you might find that why
that might be somewhere to start if
you're courageous enough why did you
reject me go and catch a person you're
too short or you're this or your breath
things whatever find out whatever it is
be be courageous they're too short
there's nothing you can do about it so
have the courage to accept things you
can't change that's fine but there are
plenty of very confident charismatic
short guys out there getting women so
it's not the short thing it's it's who
you're being you know what's interesting
just being honest social media and like
having people mess it like you know
sometimes I do one-on-ones or sometimes
people message me with like problems or
whatever I found that men are so much
more willing to take feedback than women
true where it's like if a woman if you
even imply it's something with her for
the reason that she's single it's like
all hell breaks loose like I always say
this like if you're single the men you
want don't want you yeah because if the
men you want want to do you'd be with
them yeah and but it's like somehow
that's offensive just like the same way
that if if the girls like if you're not
having sex like the women you want
aren't sleeping with you yeah and it's
it's it's it's it's but the thing is
though even though I think women are
much more likely to do a lot of
self-development work on themselves
from what I've seen a lot of men
if there's a crisis women's
self-development is this it's journaling
it's plastic surgery
um it's healing which never includes
actual therapy and if it does it's
short-lived and not consistent you know
I vehemently
engage in it more men are a lot more
stubbornness in life in terms of
coaching men men tend to be a lot more
stubborn but I think they're a lot more
realistic I think sometimes women can be
a lot more deluded about the actual real
world so taking all this action but it
may not like you said like let me look
at myself men tend to be a lot more
stubborn though about doing that work
for themselves that's the difference I
think if both can tweak it women need to
be a lot more realistic about the world
you're right if you're not getting the
guys you want you need to look at
yourself so it's not the men you need
and it's all it's okay whereas men tend
to do it after the horse is bolted that
you know men will do it after say the
marriage is failed or after something's
gone wrong then they start like that's
what I mean like when when I have men
like ask me about you know whatever DM
me message me and if I give them advice
like they'll come back in a month or two
months later and have actually improved
where it's like women it's just not the
same they I never they do but look at
the stats with men though you know the
statue of men are getting worse you know
one-third of men I think it's just five
and six men are being divorced I think
it's because men just don't think the
juice is worth the squeeze anymore it's
like it's like they do all this and what
do they get on the other side if men do
it on mass they would change the world
that's what men don't get but men truly
demanded a certain level of behavior
they'll change it but men are falling
for the first trap they're hitting up
these girls with likes and they're
telling you women they're amazing
actually creating the very world but I'm
saying that they compare starts it the
women start it because they start with
the Thirsty I don't see a second I don't
sorry to interrupt you by the way I
don't see as men against women I'm just
saying what kind of world do you want to
create as your action in alignment with
the world you want to create but my
point is that like I think the women
need to start before the man but what
they don't then what are you gonna do I
mean I mean I think like it's gonna more
and more men are gonna be sexless and I
think I think it's actually going to be
in a world where there's more
relationships like this to be honest
thank you for something no no but
statistically there can only be a few of
you that do yeah the stats won't eat but
that's the point is that more and more
men will be sexless the trend is heading
that way so what does that mean the rest
of us are sharing I think more and more
women will be childless I think 50
probably yeah and verse 30 will be
single and childless and that's what so
I think if women don't improve that's
the future that we're going to see I
wanted to comment on the the rejection
thing so like what I found over 10 years
of coaching this stuff now is that most
guys have this unrealistic expectation
that they want every girl to like them
so I tell them like if you were cold
calling in sales or you were knocking
doors it doesn't matter if you're the
best salesman in the world you're going
to encounter people that just tell you
to [__] off or they're going to tell you
I'm not interested and a lot of those
things are outside your control like
there exists girls that have boyfriends
and husbands that don't want to cheat
when you talk to them in the club
there's girls that are in a bad mood
they don't like you for whatever reason
instead of taking that personally and
thinking I suck think okay that one's
just not interested this one probably
will but most men get deflated and then
they bring that negative energy into the
next interaction and then that causes
them to get rejected with a higher it'd
be hard not to I mean I worked in sales
I sold the copiers and I'm telling you
there's nothing worse than selling it
you just like to sell like a stand-up
ten thousand dollar copy machine
who wants that and I'm like I I can't
even imagine because when I did that job
it was so soul sucking yeah that I'm
like go getting rejected and that
contributes to the problem right because
the guys have to develop almost like an
emotional resilience yeah yeah you have
to or you just have like this thick skin
and you just know that when you hit
those girls that are interested there's
gonna be other girls that are interested
and but a lot of guys will take it
personally I get clients they'll go up
get two or three rejections and they
just give up and they stop approaching
for the night so what's what's your
advice to men that want to overcome
their fear of rejection well I tell them
to follow uh the old school three-second
rule right so you have less than three
seconds to go in once you see the
attractive girl and then assume it's
gonna go well and if it doesn't don't
take it personally and I give them
strategies for how to open properly
right like with direct eye contact
speaking loud enough smiling Etc versus
like coming in Meek and passive and this
and that so I give them chances to give
or give them strategies to give them the
best chances but then also be realistic
about the fact that it's not going to
work out with some girls no matter how
good you get no matter how high value
get or anything there's still gonna be
girls who don't like you and there's
coaches that are like when you get good
enough there's no more rejections that's
false or you're never going to get
flaked on a date it's like really people
don't have things come up with their
schedule so these are just part of the
game people have to be able to just deal
with those things and not take it super
personally what about the ladies what's
your advice that to men that want to
overcome their fear of rejection I
haven't heard too much from you
okay I want to hear from these three
first I feel like the more that you do
something the more confidence you have
when you do it like rejection is not
always rejection I like the phrase
rejections redirection so it's like just
do it there's a quote I don't know what
it's like it's like confidence is the
amount of times you do something okay or
something like that basically just do it
just try to put yourself out there
what's a good opening line and I want
the guys to say if you think these are
good that a guy should use to a girl I
want I want the dating coaches to break
it
oh see I don't know I'll have ribs like
that I like
I'm joking
um I like Corner glasses
um
um okay I like on that guy says Hey
excuse me you're looking really
beautiful today
um oh say hi um how are you did it like
something like that I don't know I like
I like to be complimented like oh oh do
you need help with it I don't know if
they see me doing something oh oh what
are you doing here today I don't know
like nice not like
forward like so the good opening line is
high you look very beautiful today how
are you yeah yeah no no how you look
very beautiful today like
like what's your name like where are you
from like oh do you mind if I could um
good or bad uh it depends on like you
know if he's like kissing your ass or
like supplicator in the dark but if it's
just like a nice comment that's fine
yeah yeah now that you ask me I think
I'm part of the problem that we're
talking about because if a guy was to
move to Miller Street I wouldn't take
him seriously for sure that's the thing
yeah I think I would just assume that he
does that with everyone but he's single
so yeah
he wouldn't say the higher you're
beautiful
okay okay so you think it's cringe you
think it's okay it depends I mean like
those like London digging guys were like
hello I thought you're hot and like that
and they're just doing that like in Mass
right yeah that's why he said it depends
on how you say it that's a nice thing my
opener for 10 years has just been I want
to meet you real quick it's like very
direct I wanted to meet you and you say
like when they're like yeah yes that's
that's the way but I hope pedestal oh my
God you're beautiful how many times did
she have that no no like that but like
you're putting it on a kind of level of
oh my God you're so beautiful I'm not
used to know because hey how's it going
what's your name how's it going it
depends on the frame of how it comes
across like you don't want a guy that
comes up wow you're like the most
amazing you don't want that she's like
oh I just saw you I thought you look
really beautiful like you know what are
you doing around here like what are you
doing today I like that kind of thing
what's your advice to you guys and
what's your opening line My love
language My love language is acts of
service so if it's something very simple
as let me get that for you as he's
opening the doors my knees start to go
weak or even yeah or even at the bars
like like let me get that for you I'm
just like okay all right it's like Jay
Waller he says don't open doors for
girls
I still believe in that
um but also with me I'm very I'm a
person that's very aware and I also know
that rejection is very hard so if a guy
does take does approach me I know it's
taken him a lot to be able to do that so
I'm not going to reject him and be rude
and say oh I'm not interested I'm gonna
go with the flow the conversation and
I'll let him down gently but I think it
also what you were saying that you're
the problem it takes us to be as human
beings to be empathetic as well to
understand that he is still a human he
does still have feelings it has taken a
lot for him to approach you so just be
nice yeah for sure so what do you think
of her I like that because that's quite
natural isn't let me get a dolphin hey
where you have to yeah her name how's it
going yeah
I don't know
you cannot be I don't like anything
that's like all like contrived I mean
that's not gonna even happen that often
right like in terms of like situation
depending
I think just starting the conversation
and being direct as long as there's not
like fancy gaming gimmicky stuff then
that's thumbs up for me okay what about
you what's your advice to men what's a
pickup line that you like
a specific pickup line but I'd say be
confident not arrogant and be just be
straightforward what's the difference
between confidence and arrogance well I
feel like in the context that I'm
looking here
with the context that we're talking
about you don't want to come off as I
know I'm coming to get you and I'm
getting you and I'm I've got you do you
get one do you know what I'm doing
confidence no I think I think confidence
is I don't mind getting rejected but if
you reject me I'll walk off like a man
and I won't oh you're dead anyway or you
know oh that's the worst of a guy yeah
he's mad yeah okay thing though yeah
like for example no yeah that's that
just to you and that happens in sales
too right I don't know if you saw that
in sales but I did sales for a summer to
see how it translates to game and
there's like rookies that go up to the
door and the guy slams the door on their
face and they're like yelling stuff at
the guy where's like a veteran who's
like okay that person is not interested
and they don't take it personally yeah
versus like trying to get even no in the
UK guys take it personally they'll be
like oh you're ugly anyway
but that's young guys yeah
I don't know if I did that common I just
like here and there yeah yeah yeah I
don't know it depends
um so did you have a line or no I don't
have a line but I'd say me personally I
like it when a guy starts off with a
compliment but not an obvious compliment
not anything to do with my face whether
it be something about my style or the
way I carry myself oh so if a guy
compliments your style yeah something
yeah would it good or bad
that's good yeah that's cool okay uh
what about you yeah I usually like I
started compliment this style or
something that because like if I'm
approach a person like uh for sure it's
because there's something that I'm
interested in that person I don't know
if they approach you
oh I think you're really cool yeah like
you see me really cool what's your name
oh can you talk oh let's think fun facts
okay that's a compliment though yeah do
you like that one yeah I mean as long as
it got like the biggest problem I've
seen is that like a lot of coaches say
like come in and say oh you look like
you like this or like you know just say
really cheesy fancy gimmicky stuff where
they're like using lines or like you
know these these clever pickup lines or
like different stuff like that and that
just has like this air of like this is a
a little tactic that I'm trying to win
you over with yeah like all the common
theme between all the responses is they
want the guy to be like genuine and
actually like showing that he's
interested without hiding it right like
guys that come up and ask you for
directions like it's obvious that they
don't want directions yeah but like you
like lose maybe a little respect because
he's not having the balls to be
straightforward and that's the iron if
you think about it you only get good at
that if you deal with rejection right
because it's almost the emotional
calibration and you have to deal with
the rejection to get that inward that
didn't work well that didn't work with
that type of woman so you have to do it
in order to have the hey how's it going
how are you doing that's the beauty of
rejection what's your line
my line oh
um
yo what's happening
every London guy ever is that what he
said pretty much I did I did yeah yeah I
have to own that but also I want you
approached him yeah okay how what line
did you use
it wasn't really a line it was an
ultimatum a little bit if you don't want
me there's lots of men doing she really
played the kind of manipulation with it
we were good friends for a long time
though to be honest I've seen him did
your friend zone him or did she friend
zone you no no one friends only travel
when I first saw I was in a relationship
so and then we just became friends we
were doing a lot of the same coaching
and self-development together and then
when I got single she kind of did the
ultimatum look you better take me now
because you don't someone else will want
me
you know but for the minute I first saw
it it was just like love at first time
but I wasn't a relationship that's crazy
that's nice
the girl because of her it just didn't
work out well yeah dump her if it was I
thought it was like right because
where I met at the contest I met her we
were doing a lot of self-development
training with a massive um
self-development country
um uh company and integrity was a very
important thing in terms of the training
we were doing and I had to learn that
because I've come from a culture of just
chatting up girls willy-nilly right but
I still never really believe in cheating
necessarily I'm avoids because my
parents have been married for 60 plus
years I've always believed the monogamy
and the rest of it but from an Integrity
point of view I was already in a
relationship it's a straight one I'm not
gonna even go there I can acknowledge oh
my God she's beautiful that's exactly
the kind of woman I want to be with but
because of my situation I was like I'm
not going anywhere near there and when
it naturally ended and I was single and
we were friends for ages she then made
the move and I was like hell yeah I'm
not threat because for the minute I met
you you were perfect you know fair or
man yeah I don't know I don't know what
to feel about that I don't know whether
to be like
respect will be like the iris but what
if it had worked out with the girl
you're in the relationship with yeah
I've never got into a relationship with
her you'd have been in love she was an
opportunist
I own my action I've seen that guy and
there's a lot of values that he have
that I value now here's the thing right
even though he was in a relationship I
didn't really interfere at all we were
friends we probably chat once every now
and then now when he was uh not in that
relationship I was not his type anymore
because when he met me I was the perfect
size you know I was perfect look I lost
it I had to work my you know self to be
that person and that's nothing I own who
I am you know I mean I know exactly what
I want and if there is an opportunity of
course I'm gonna go for it you know
there's no shame about it yeah go for
what you want yeah yeah and my dreams
yeah and my advice for guys because I
know that's the question is don't listen
to women they most of the time they
don't know personally I don't know what
I want from a man go and find someone
that inspires you a man that really have
that perfect relationship there's so
many coaches out there coaching you
about relationship but they're not in
one go and find a relationship that
inspires you and get his advice he will
be able to open his heart and share his
advice with you so question for the
women have you ever approached a guy
and have you ever been rejected
no yes yes yeah oh cool okay tell me
tell me about it I've approached but not
been rejected oh you've never been
rejected you have you approached yeah
have you been rejected yeah what
happened
um it's just when I open up and say what
I want from my future and what I like
for example that I want to be married
and I want to have family they tend to
be like you said that immediately yeah
okay yeah okay I'm pretend I'm the guy
well it's not not a bar and say oh I
want to get married like on the first
date or something like that yeah on the
first day I'm talking about like
approaching a guy like cold approach oh
no no no no never have you ever cold
approached uh I think I have
at a bar at a club yeah they're always
into it yeah okay what about you have
you ever called approach no no no have
you ever called
I don't think so no that's interesting
right I would know I don't know I don't
think so no I have yeah
no never yeah you've never coded
and what about you have you ever
approached a guy yeah were you ever
rejected yes really yeah how what do you
say
um I remember like once I was like in
the grocery there was this really hot
guy like it was like John like exactly
no there was like my type like this and
then I was like oh my God but I was like
you know it was like civil engineer work
in a site construction so well like
almost like the majority of my time I
wasn't like dressed up I wasn't like
cute it was like with boots like jeans
like you know
and now I could come up to him and he
said oh I'm sorry I'm married and I said
okay
um he's married that's good
and I think like when I was younger too
like I I don't know I think getting
rejected is like part of life yeah
I'm curious from the guys is there a
rejection that was like your worst
rejection that you can think of well
I've called approach like probably tens
of thousands of times but you know every
now and then there'll be a girl that
just tells you for like tries to insult
you personally or something like that
and that that can hurt sometimes right
you get over that like you just you just
learn that's gonna happen sometimes but
especially for like clients that aren't
used to approaching if they hear
something that early on where the person
says like oh no I don't like you because
of this and this that sticks in their
head and they think every girl thinks
that and it can be like debilitating and
I can take them out of the game I think
for me the the worst approach
um rejections I can remember is when
they don't say anything they pretend
they don't hear you no they look at you
like how dare you even think you have
what it takes to come up to me and I
don't say it's just everything in the
eyes it's saying that and you feel like
some girls friendly don't hear you too
like they just stand there but it'd be
nice if they're pretending they don't
think about the ones that hurt you
I'm almost insulted that you've come up
to them that happened to me like two
days ago with a girl okay I I just was
complimenting her outfit I was like oh
my gosh that's so cute she just looked
at me no and I know she's I know she
heard me and then she just like kept
like I was sitting at like a table bar
you know what I mean and she just kept
she just like looked the other way okay
then then I go to this other place right
and she's there and then she she starts
talking to me and she's like can you
take my Instagram picture I'm like [__]
I'm like [__]
it becomes almost like funny though like
in the beginning like if a girl would
ignore I'd be like oh my God like I'm
horrible yeah but now like if I got to a
bar and I'm like okay I wanted to meet
you real quick and the girl's like
pretentious in here I'll be like and I
know you hear me can I just talk to her
a sec if they're still not responsive
then I'll just walk you know just walk
away right away but it doesn't even
register you get to the point I mean if
I was single as well it's like you just
don't care yeah but it's almost like
it's almost like funny too you're like
look at this okay the chat is saying
tell me you didn't take your picture I
did I'm not even going
[Music]
just kind of take taking it back to be
honest I was just like is this what men
go through like that but they're good
for yeah
I feel like I'm a part he had one minute
of a lifetime for so many years yeah
yeah I was like I don't like this look
at that woman that became a man for a
bit wasn't it the story where she became
a masturbate she committed suicide on
the life the surface they say yeah this
is only a man for a short time well I
don't think most women aren't like I
don't think we really noticed the
privilege we're given in society just
from being young women where we're like
treated better by people and the first
time this happened to me I am I worked
in a sales job and I was the only girl
in the office and people would always
help me with whatever I wanted you know
what I mean yeah and all the guys around
me would be like oh it's because you're
a girl it's because you're a girl and I
was like no it's because I'm so bubbly
and I work hard
yeah okay yeah and then I found out it
was in fact because I was a girl because
I feel like you're not even in like a
romantic way but I think that men just
have more of an inclination to like help
yeah
what it's more fun than helping it go
yeah yeah even if it's not like it also
was ever late though because then
there's also a sense of not taking women
as seriously as well as it flips doesn't
it I've never had like I've never felt
that was an issue to be honest and I
would I've worked in like predominantly
male dominated Fields I think it's an
advantage not a disability yeah but I
think you've probably learned how to you
know you're powerful Mercy you've
learned how to I'm the same I will
always navigate whatever you know
limitations Society based on Me based as
a black man for instance I don't care
yeah but some people don't learn that
skill so they actually internalize no
I'm not enough excuse I think there's
zero limitations as a woman like zero
none unless it's like a string I agree
and we'll go lie yeah I feel like the
girls that whine about going to
corporate and having a hard time like I
just think it's an excuse they're just
big whiners I don't think so Pearl I
have to say there is there is a listen
there's women do get treated by
compassion people help them out but
there is also the view of like oh women
is it weaker than a man and there's
nothing wrong with that logic like
physically woman is weaker than a man
but if a woman's trying to get some
level of finances or authority she will
definitely get a background
I disagree I think there's quote there's
quotas for women I think women get put
in positions they shouldn't be in all
the time what do you mean like I feel
like women get put in positions they're
actually not qualified for and they're
not the best person for the job because
of quotas and diversity Hunters yeah
some some um
women or people of color do have to
prove themselves more in order to be
getting taken seriously no so I just
think as for women in my experience I
don't think there's any disadvantage and
most of the girls I know that complain
about it are just kind of lazy to be
honest I don't agree with you perro I
get you but I don't agree with you given
that I'm with my partner and sometimes I
go for what he's going for I put my
hands up I don't speak as perfect
English and I'm not intelligent as much
as he is but there's a lot of positions
that he gets picked when I don't you
know maybe he's just better he is
unfortunately yes that's right but
there's sometimes when they give him
chances but give me a chance to just
prove that I'm better or maybe I'm equal
in some there is a lot of places that
I'm quite equal but I feel like it's
like a mindset thing like if I if I get
passed up for a job with a dude like I'm
not gonna think it's because of my
gender I'm thinking I'm gonna think it's
because I'm not good enough yeah but
that's what I mean there's two different
things at play one there is a
disadvantage for some people in society
whether it's based on your race whatever
it might be even height they've showed
studies about that but I think the
second thing is who are you in the face
of that and that's what you're alluding
to yeah so I don't care there are times
of course I mean I've grown up as a
young black boy how many times I've got
stopped by police of course
statistically I knew there was more I
have friends that would walk around
whatever in their pockets they never get
stopped as I do I get it it's a reality
but my thing is who are you going to be
in the face of it that's the difference
so I recognize that Society does treat
different people differently that's
that's just true but my thing is I don't
do the victim thing because of it I
think that's what you're talking about
you're not a victim if fact I actually
turned on his head because it happened
I'm gonna go even harder that's it and I
was brought up told you you're black
you're gonna have to work three times as
hot and so I think yeah I'm not going to
complain no why do I have to do it three
times
and it's given me an advantage
disadvantage gives you an advantage you
see it with like rappers in that they're
hungry get away they come from they mean
it when they say get rich or die trying
so there are discrimination against them
but it makes them what I don't like is
victim culture but I just I think that
Society openly discriminates against men
way more than women and like and I I
think if that wasn't the case like there
wouldn't be quotas in these jobs yeah
like I think people want women in
leadership positions because in a lot of
companies they have diversity hires true
but that's quite a recent thing I would
say probably isn't in the last
generation I mean it's been implemented
since like the 60s at least in the US
since the 60s yeah last animation or two
yeah but that's I mean I'm 26 so that's
two of two of my lifetimes that's quite
a long time to me
it's the pendulum thing isn't it I think
his song too far now it just sounds like
let's get someone diverse in there even
though they're not I mean I think of our
um it's bad that I say about our
Chancellor of course an absolute
nightmare I wonder if he was thrust in
that position next thing you know he had
the most terrible him in the Prime
Minister his trust you know that's an
example I think where people just put
into position because they can agreement
swinging I actually don't really see it
like women were discriminated against
like ever because I just think that we
had different roles like we could say
that men were discriminated against
because they had to go to war we didn't
have to go I don't think I just think
Society was set up differently I don't
think it's discrimination in that I mean
give an example for instance right if it
wasn't for the fact that men went to war
women would never have been allowed in
these industrial jobs it's not
discrimination it's just a limitation
based on an assumption of your woman you
can't do it strength you know or you're
black you can't do it well I mean I
think when it comes to war like we can't
now but women did women did fill the
positions that men left behind I was
talking about war oh actually we're
going yeah I mean me and you could fight
you're even if I'm the strongest woman
you're gonna win
physically yeah I mean there are some
female climbers out there that run rings
around something if women were doing so
well in the military they wouldn't
continually lower the requirements for
them too yeah
like they literally had to lower the
requirement for us to become a seal I
think when it's physically like that but
definitely in society there have been
instances where people have not been
given a chance because of an assumption
about what they were capable of and when
they were given that chance you could
see that they excelled I mean as a time
the NBA wasn't full of black players you
know there were times for answer we've
got a friend who's um a black um
football agent there was a time that was
unheard of he was a time when women
weren't seen able to run a football club
and yeah I'm just talking about gender
yeah so when my what I was talking about
was when I just don't think women were
ever really discriminated against I
think Society was different
what's the definition of discrimination
about like earning differentials right
even the modern days you treat it
differently because of their gender
isn't it really is what you think I come
from a culture when it's the opposite to
the West right now women do get abused I
was about to say these are the people
that I know personally the man will
cheat she can't say any word and she
will get hit and there's no one's gonna
stand for her she gonna step by her
parents stay in that marriage you've got
kids and you're not coming back to us
I'm talking about in the west I don't
know what but that's what I'm saying I
think we could do different things right
that's one he says it's been shifted
right so there's a lot of women right
happen because of that because it that
was like 100 years ago here so the woman
stood and raised their voice but it
became quite toxic right now and I think
what's really missing is balance yeah
that's possible yeah there definitely
was a time when women were discriminated
it's happening yeah just along and
gender lines around on classlines at the
time for instance working class guys
couldn't vote so there's always been a
sense where power's been concentrated in
the hands of whatever privilege it was
and that the other had to fight for that
oh they can actually that's my point is
like it wasn't it was about like roles
and responsibilities like it wasn't just
open discrimination but I mean it was
but it wasn't like for example like they
always talk about how women couldn't
vote but the majority of women didn't
want to vote like if they asked them
they pulled them and the majority of
women didn't want to vote because it
came with being drafted and so how it's
it's not really discrimination it's
roles and responsibilities where the men
were responsible for protecting where
the women were responsible for staying
out but before women got their suffrage
wasn't it the case that men who were
fighting also didn't weren't didn't have
a chance to vote so the majority of
people didn't have the chance but I
don't remember exactly how it was
structured it's been it's been a bit
since I've looked at it but like I
actually because there's always this
narrative that like women were oppressed
and put down and that's always what I
thought until I found out I started
researching the anti-suffragettes or
whatever they were called and they're
basically like women that were against
women voting and I was like why on Earth
would women not want the right to vote
and it turned out it was because it came
with the responsibility because when you
think about it you're voting at least in
the U.S for the commander-in-chief so
that's the person that's in charge of
the army so it kind of makes sense for
you to have some skin in the game but
you don't think that historically women
weren't discriminated against and you
know
forget like even more but you say women
authors had to come out as men in order
to be taken seriously women
photographers had to pretend they were
men in order to be taken seriously
they've been time and time again
instances in in society where women had
to pretend to be men in order to be
taken seriously I mean same with the
first female doctor I believe it was in
France I think if you had to pick women
by and large being discriminated against
in men by and large being discriminated
against I would say men were
discriminated against more
men and women I'm just because then it
becomes our men have had it worse than
women and it becomes this battle I'm
talking just purely in terms of you know
women discriminate against and so with
men has there ever been discrimination
ever sure but do I do I think it's like
this narrative that by and large like
women had such a horrible life and were
oppressed and all this stuff yeah no I
agree with you I think that's been
fanned by certain elements of third wave
and fourth and fifth waves of feminism
that's true but definitely historically
women have definitely been discriminated
against and so have many men I really
think that feminism it's all the same
wave um I think it is it and always has
been a hate group always yeah oh yeah
because it started in 1888 in Seneca
Falls New York um and the first
anti-suffragettes they planned
assassinations
um they yeah people don't realize that
yeah people like they weren't this like
peaceful group that people think about
um so yeah I think it's always been the
same movement which is freedom we want
the freedom without the responsibility
and it started with the right to vote
because they wanted the freedom of
voting without the responsibility of
having any skin in the game and I think
it always started with wanting to
destruct the family because if you look
at the anti-suffragettes um which like
if you look at their writings about why
they didn't want to vote they would talk
about how
um this was the beginning of the
destruction of the family because before
then you trusted your husband um you
trusted his leadership and so that it
was in they were right it was the
beginning of the destruction of the
family because the policies that
feminism has
placed and caused has eroded the family
in the west
I probably wouldn't go to that extreme
that it was based on hey I think there
was legitimate
um you know need for women to have some
level of emancipation because at some
point they were the property of the
husbands how they could do whatever they
want with them I mean there are some
things where women couldn't say anything
about it I mean you say in Islamic
cultures now Islamic coach is only a bit
it's pretty much where Victorian culture
was in some instance I think there was a
genuine need by women to free themselves
and give them the opportunities to be
all they could be in life I mean I I
think I think you could my argument
isn't was it was it needed or not needed
my my argument is it was always freedom
without responsibility at the expense of
man
and so when it starts with the vote it
was the freedom of voting without the
responsibility of going to war so if you
elect someone batshit crazy into Power
who has to deal with that Consequence
the men not the women and I know some
people argue we don't go to war today
which is you know that's a fair argument
but when it started it was freedom
without responsibility at the expense of
men
this is going deep yeah I think it might
be I I say I'll tell you what I say a
little bit I think they've been
pioneering women that have paved the way
for you to have a show like yours that's
that successful and they had to
sacrifice a lot for you to be yeah and I
think legitimately they did it in order
to really have freedom I think even they
would be appalled at how far it's gone
today well and I and I think that's
always what people say like how how do
you have these thoughts when you have a
podcast like yeah of course I benefit
individually but when I when I look at
things as a society do I think that
ultimately that was good those policies
that feminism has passed as a society
you know I can acknowledge I have
individual benefits that benefit me
individually that I don't think have
helped the society buy at large yeah no
and I and for me I will defend to death
you're right to say that and that's what
I love about what you do people may not
agree with everything you say but I love
the fact you say it because it starts
this discourse this conversation that's
going on I do believe a lot of the
movement men right now is causing a lot
more harm you know we need fathers back
in the home we've seen the harm that's
done we need a lot more why are you
throwing out the baby with the buff or
there was a lot of traditions that were
great getting rid of them some women are
not happy well and we don't we act like
we don't need men I mean even the fact
that we have Envy like women getting in
vitro fertilization without without
having a husband it's like you're acting
like you don't need a father to raise a
child and that's not important yeah yeah
absolutely right I think we men need
women no man's ever going to say they
don't need women
and I think women need men and I think
that's what I want to see and I think
those are the conversations that we
really need to be having how can we
bring it back together but not go all
the way back to the days where women
don't have a vote it's never going to go
back to that yeah thank God
to go back is to embrace more
Traditional Values there yeah that's the
only way because like yeah that's the
only way you need to be more traditional
but
but this is the problem I feel like
whenever we have that conversation it's
always about the men being more
traditional but imagine the women need
to be more traditional as well which
also like tradition that includes
letting your husband lead you and submit
to him what do you think about like
women not going to college anymore
yes uni well I don't go anyway
like it's what isn't it there's other
careers you can pursue you don't need
unique yeah you don't need you I think
if you're gonna go uni do one of the
stems if you're going to add 30 40 well
90k or whatever it might be to start the
United philosophy make it worth it crazy
yeah no what do you think about people
are doing that women not going to UNI
anymore College
um
I I think like personally that they're
never actually gonna go back to like I
think it sounds nice to say let's go
back to these Traditional Values I just
don't see it happening yeah like I just
don't I need God I see I see women
sharing less men and men being more
sexless that's what I see but then
that's just outstanded that you want to
set and then what you're not just gonna
compromise I I'm not just gonna
compromise like
you know it's actually I I'm gonna
change my mind I do think less women
should go to college because all the
degrees are getting are so stupid
no men have more stuff people need to be
more creative